yesterday we got news that the sec has
gotten an open letter from two
congressmen those two congressmen are
tom emmer who's a congressman from
minnesota and darren soto a congressman
from florida both of them wrote a letter
urging the sec to approve a spot etf if
you remember a couple of weeks ago we
actually got an approval of a bitcoin
etf the very first one but that is a
futures based etf it does not give you
exposure to the actual bitcoin itself
but more so the futures price we've seen
the performance of let's say the gbtc
product the bitcoin trust drastically
outperform bito which is the futures
based product one actually has exposure
to bitcoin the other only has exposure
to futures and there's all kinds of
differences this letter urges the sec
and says well if we have a bitcoin
futures etf then we should absolutely
have a bitcoin spot etf and so it's very
interesting to see these are two
congressmen these are not regulators
these are not people who are involved in
the financial markets these are
congressmen who are going ahead and
writing this letter now when you see
that there could just be political
stunts it could just be to get some
notoriety and some headlines but also i
think that there is an entire world
where people are starting to wake up to
the fact that their's constituents want
these assets they want exposure to it
and there may be financial firms or
institutions or maybe pensions
endowments or potentially even private
investors for one reason or another that
cannot get exposure to the actual
bitcoin themselves
and therefore they want bitcoin spot etf
exposure and so watching
congressmen start to send letters like
this is very interesting we have james
seaford who was on he was covering for
bloomberg all of the etf business that
said the next big etf decision to date
uh to watch is 11 14 which is two
sundays the sec will likely deny vanessa
application for a spot bitcoin etf but
the denial letter is likely to provide a
lot of valuable insights into how the
sec's current view of crypto and bitcoin
so when we see that we've got all of
these applications that keep coming in
over and over and over again of people
wanting to get that bitcoin spot etf
remember what we said a couple of weeks
ago having the futures based etf was a
big deal that meant that the sec and
other regulators had finally gotten
comfortable with there being an etf
structure to give people some exposure
now we're getting into the nitty-gritty
now we're getting into the details do it
should it be a spot exposure or a
futures exposure well obviously there
are people who want spot exposure so we
have two congressmen from two different
states both asking saying hey how can we
get this let's get this done do we think
that this is good
or it's completely agnostic and doesn't
matter if the congressman write the
letters or not like do we think this
actually has an impact on the decision
making given that there's a spot etf
application that is going to come up
here for decision in next couple of days
i think uh any noise is generally good
right positive noise trying to push it
forward but yeah i don't know how much
uh this will actually do i think is your
point real right like is the congress or
the congress uh men or women going to
make any difference in the approval
process no i don't think so but i think
that anytime you can see
demand from politicians demand from
business leaders demand from retail
traders etc it's a good thing and it
helps with that approval process showing
that people want this right and we've
already seen a future gtf approved spot
you would think is next we've had some
people on the show previously that think
that it's probably 12 to 24 maybe even
36 months away at the longest point um
so who knows when it'll actually come
through but there's obviously a high
demand for it and i think it would be
good for the market right we don't want
retail investors who want to own the
asset going out and buying the futures
etf that's just not that's not the best
vehicle to do that in right so you
either go buy regular bitcoin or give
them access to an etf uh another vehicle
where they can do this and not only
retailer investors right this is for
institutional traders give them access
to a vehicle where they can go do this
without owning bitcoin themselves in
their books so i think uh when it comes
down to is this going to help who knows
we're still probably a long ways away
from actually getting something improved
on the spot side but any kind of noise
that we can create to show demand i
think is a good thing
john tom and darren have been really pro
bitcoin for a while now i believe and
obviously this letter that they sent to
the sec is pro bitcoin um
and
they don't really have a lot of
influence on the sec right like they can
they can bang the drums and write these
letters and kind of put them publicly
but uh ultimately it's going to be the
sec's decision kind of when that gets
approved um and then one thing i want to
point out too is it wasn't like they
were saying a spot etf is better than a
futures etf actually a quote from their
thing is to be clear we do not intend to
say that one method of exposure is
better than the other so they're more
just saying that um
they described about the nuance
differences but they were also saying
that look if you prove to futures you
should also approve a spot etf as well
um to give people that exposure in the
market
i i do think that there's a very big
difference the thing that most people
don't understand here is one if we pull
up the letter one more time uh the
congressman explicitly state that they
are not claiming that uh one method of
exposure is better than the other right
what is what you're saying here the
thing that they are saying though uh
which i which i actually agree with is
that there are different there's
differences that investors should be
allowed to prove and i think that's your
point here john right is that like let
the investors choose which one is better
and so one of the big questions was
leading up to the etf approval was if
they only approved one etf applicant for
let's say three months then you're
basically king making that one etf
applicant as the winner now the question
goes which the sec did not do within the
first week they had multiple people in
the market but now the question is if
you are going ahead and saying hey the
future's not the spot right are you king
making in some way or you're not giving
investors choice now the art the counter
argument from the regulators which i
actually think there's a fair argument
from uh is we want to protect the
investors now are they actually
protecting investors are they not
they're experts on this stuff and so are
the etf applicants and so i think they
just need to get in a room and they need
to talk this out um in terms of what the
issues are and it comes down to this
like
uh um kind of the acts of which uh these
funds are constructed but ultimately i
think there will be a bitcoin spot etf i
think there will be a bitcoin futures
etf which we already have uh they'll
live in coexistence and it's actually
shocking because there wasn't that much
inflow to the bitcoin futures etf that
first two or three days there was tons
of flow like you know billion dollars or
so they haven't even hit two billion
dollars in the funds yet
right so like now we are a week or two
later and they kind of just plateau well
the hype has died so the hype is one
piece of it but it's not just hype right
part of it is like there was some
pent-up demand for a futures one but we
don't know if a spot had been approved
would there have been five billion
dollars that float we don't know and by
the way that might not be the best
metric to measure
is
how much capital flows the best measure
it's up to you to decide like what are
you trying to optimize for when
measuring are they successful are they
not like that's a good question do you
think that the futures etf is successful
if it stays at a billion dollars you're
talking about from an aunt perspective
like how much is in there what would be
successful yeah like if they if a year
later the bitcoin futures etf the very
first one the pro shares one has a
billion dollars in it and that's it
is that successful i think people would
be uh that would be underperforming
people's expectations i think so too
right and so it's like what is the
number is it five billion is it ten i
don't know what the number is but i just
think that people are surprised that
there's only a billion right like it
would seem that there would be way more
than just uh a billion dollars and
they're given how much hype there was on
the actual uh announcement to me a spot
etf is uh
not inevitable but it's bound to happen
i think at some point in time over the
next year right people were expecting it
to get it in q4 of this year so seeing
that not happen yet but i really do hope
that when the sec
if and when they do approve a spot etf
that they actually approve
um they approve of multiple ones at the
exact same time so it doesn't have that
kind of pent-up demand and the market
can actually decide the winner instead
of hey the sec decide that this one gets
all the capital inflow